the country's opposition leader Nelson
Shimizu is with our Africa correspondent
John sparks who's live in Harare now we
can speak to him John yes good evening I
am in central Harare I am joined by the
leader of the MDC Alliance party Nelson
Chiu Misa on what is a pretty
extraordinary day last night we had the
official results to the election where
president Emerson Man and Jaguar claimed
fifty point eight percent of the vote
today a press conference held by Nelson
cha Misa was essentially broken up by
the riot police until they left the
premises they have now issued what most
people would consider to be a fairly
humiliating apology quite an
extraordinary day mr. cha Misa we have
had an election from that that has been
described by the president as free and
fair we've also had shooting on the
streets on Wednesday in this city is
this the new Zimbabwe or definitely not
so in fact I'm extremely concerned that
the leopard has not changed its spots
and the skin is the same the same old
ways that we saw in the yesterday a
dispensation of zanu-pf politics of
terrorism politics of violence politics
of terror politics of tanks and guns on
the streets that is totally unacceptable
but what is more disturbing is the
electron shanigan
and tips of the will of the people
the manipulation and tampering with the
will of the people is something that we
don't take lightly
people in Zimbabwe are extremely
concerned this is not just filling in
the empty cell lines it's a universal
feeling including those in Jan opf who
do know that they did not win this
election if anything they just got a
declaration from the Zimbabwe electoral
commission which is not an expression of
the will of the people
Electoral Commission's says that you
have not won the presidency they say
that the MDC alliance will not control
the Parliament this is not a good result
for your party well it's a very good
result for our party because if you look
at Parliament we've done very well we
have managed to sweep away all the
citizens we are in charge of all the
Metropole in the country we are also in
charge of all the local authorities that
are significant so the greatest part of
taxpayers and the budget that is going
to sustain this economy it's going to
come from the MDC alliance dominated
areas in the royal areas we've also made
significant inroads but you must
acknowledge that we've had problems in
certain areas where food is being abused
as a political point not only that we
also have intimidation
command approach to politics command
politics
command elections a command voting where
people are commented into voting for a
particular candidate in zanu-pf or else
they risk losing their lives or not
getting food this has been a problem and
this is part of why we are challenging
those results in the parliamentary
so once we have successfully challenged
those results we'll get the majority in
parliament and of course we've won the
popular vote in the president it's
there's no doubt that we have a popular
what ahead of me some Langara he knows
it he acknowledges it of course he
doesn't acknowledge it he does tonight
he said in his press conference that he
won the election freely and fairly
thus his claim but he knows the truth
acknowledging the truth and of course
what is claiming now is experience
because he has been in cahoots with the
Zimbabwe Electoral Commission to try and
manipulate an alter the will of the
people which is not possible and this is
why we are pursuing all our legal and
constitutional
roots to make sure that we negate this
kind of cheating it's not possible
people watch it but you can see that
there's been cheating on the part of
Zack and also on the part of mr.
minagawa what is Nelson chemise do next
what does the party do next you say
you're going to go to the course do you
trust the courts well it's not a
question of trusting the cause it's a
question of trusting the authenticity
and the currents of the message that we
have and the kind of evidence we had
with overwhelming evidence of areas
where certain figures were inflated in
favor of mr. managua areas where they
deflated figures that were are coming
the embassy alliance side so do you have
evidence hard core evidence in fact
paper evidence we live in forms which
our polling station best forms those who
are going to use at appropriate levels
in engaging Zach but also in
articulating our message to the
international world but more importantly
we want to appreciate the support we've
had from the international community for
genuine free and fair elections and also
for making sure that there's
accountability which has been lacking in
this election do you really think you
can overturn the presidential result in
the courts we weren't going to overturn
anything if anything what we are going
to over ten is the declaration by Zach
the result is in our favor such as if
we've been defeated with more votes than
mr. minagawa in the popular vote I won
the presidency mr. mellenburg was then
declared president so there's an anomaly
we need to undo the damage done by Zach
because of their lack of integrity their
lack of consistent and of course there
are partisanship their bias is
unbelievable it even stinks in high
heaven do you want people to come out
onto the streets are you calling for
demonstrations I've seen what's happened
earlier this week I've said that because
of homelessness joblessness and
hopelessness in the country people are
already in the streets so I can't call
them to come where they are already they
are resident in the streets
automatically they are there because of
poverty in on disenfranchisement and of
course the disappointment that they had
a raw deal of missed opportunities and
neglected advantages on account of what
is happening in this country so what I
simply have to do is to activate those
people in show them direction in a
peaceful manner to say we have the right
to protect our voice defend our vote and
of course make sure that our vote counts
in terms of where we want this country
to go on opportunities on transformation
and of course most importantly on the
issue of prosperity Zimbabweans need a
fighting platform a fighting advantage a
fighting chance and for them to be able
to gather they need a leadership that
governs and governs defended President
Managua extended an olive branch to you
tonight he says you have a crucial role
to play in this country what's your
response to that of course we must
extend an olive branch as a person with
gracious in defeat I have to be
magnanimous in victory which I have been
and this is why I've been making an
effort to try and reach him to say how
do we move forward now that we have won
this election
now that we've had this
kind of bungling by the Zimbabwe
Electoral Commission how do we negate
this kind of electro skullduggery which
does not help our country in terms of
refocusing the country internationally
as a country that is ready to join the
family of Nations we don't want to
continue to have this pariah status and
this Banana Republic but to be able to
do that we must also be able to
chlorinate our own domestic processes in
a manner that gives confidence to
citizens but also the international
community investors included it is
president Managua who will be
inaugurated you you will not be
inaugurated he will a Paris with him
said only not inauguration it takes two
to tango we have been very key in this
we got the majority vote we got the
popular vote with overwhelming evidence
of where he cheated and where there was
deception in cahoots with certain forces
that we are going to excel you know
exhume and reveal so will not allow an
inauguration that is done without an
understanding of the issues that we have
to deal with let us have an inauguration
on the basis of a true and accurate
reflection of the will of the people so
don't worry about his wishes wishes are
not necessarily the reality we have to
come in and a cetera position who is
president Emerson melanca gua is he a
longtime member of the old regime or is
he a new democrat is he the man
promising a new dawn in your view who is
he president Managua is the man who has
presided over the past three four days
of chaos the chaos in the Zimbabwe
electoral commission with a cheating and
manipulation of the figures in or
fidgeting with the result president
anger is the president of you know tanks
on the streets for people are supposed
to be celebrating and in jubilation
where on earth would you have an
election result that does not inspire
and confidence any happiness or some
kind of jubilation on the streets you
call it a day of mourning today yes
indeed it is a day of mourning because
one day our mourning is the kind of
dishonesty in government the kind of
deficit of integrity or
the part of Zach which is supposedly an
independent national institution so
that's prison a goggle for you the kind
of harassment you know and persecution
of journalists in the National
journalists and observers that you saw
today at our press conference that is
the kind of presidents that we would
want to run away from and this is why we
want to assign a new president that we
are ready to offer look at what they've
done to our party supporters invading
our headquarters taking away our
information and continue to harass in
the rest our leaders in the movement for
Democratic Change Alliance that is an
issue we are going to confront and that
is present in Agua for you this is a
crucial moment for the government they
are seeking finance they're seeking
funds from the IMF the World Bank other
international lenders they want this
election to be judged to be free and
fair to have that box ticked so they can
then go on to the international markets
what is your message to the foreign
observers well let the observation be
based on what they saw and what they saw
is absence of freeness absence of
credibility in the processes there is
actually a deficit of process integrity
if you look at the value chain of the
whole voting process the ballot process
in terms of the printing you go to the
way people voted it's clear that the
conditions and circumstance for a free
and fair election do not exist and what
they then choose to say is what we
respect because they also have an
independent assessment of the situation
but our message is that please help us
help ourselves to liberate ourselves
from the claws and manacles of
oppression and this dictatorship that
tribes on terrorizing citizens and
abusing ordinary people who are unarmed
but then targeted using you know open
fire and also live bullets do you feel
safe do you have to be brave to be in
opposition politics in this country well
I suppose it takes a lot of sacrifice it
takes a lot of fire service it takes a
lot of
the courage and I must give tribute to
dr. Richard Morgan Tsvangirai who was
carrying the mantle for 18 years I'm
just coming in again hours with him but
I'm coming in as the leader I have to
make sure that I balance two things
reorganizing the country reforming it
and reconstructing our economy but also
dealing with the party to make sure that
it's Encarta is a permanent feature in
the lament of democracy and Democrats
you drew huge crowds across the country
with thousands of aesthetic people but
the reality is that you will spend
another five years in opposition that is
the most likely reality here the
realities that were in government
already when government in the local
authorities when government in the
cities we are in charge of the
provincial government of Parana
provincial government of La Jolla we're
in charge of the cities and towns as
mayor as counselors we're in charge of
the central government as president and
I know that you may not believe but very
soon you will see what we are talking
about we are ready to happen we have
been given the mandate by the people
people voted overwhelmingly and we thank
the people of Zimbabwe for reporting
such confidence in us and we are not
going to disappoint them you are
relatively young for political figures
in this country you are a lawyer and a
pastor is this what you thought you
would be doing well it's something that
I never budgeted for but the truth of
the matter is that I'm driven by the
passion to do the best for my country
and to do the best for my generation so
that is what drives me I'm where I never
anticipated out be as you know I was
deputized in dr. Morgan Frank Wright he
passed on and now we can on the mental
and artistic making sure that we achieve
real change it's a tough job but those
challenges have really fortified us for
the test ahead and the party is split is
there the party so United in fact we're
so happy we have done so well
two million what is not a joke even by
the tally of Z which is disputed so over
two million was tells you that we are
alive and kicking party we're a young
dynamic party you know one credible
Ganassi no doubt
and continent that is sure to deliver
the more classy to the people of
Zimbabwe and of course the African
continent so the party so United yes
whether the individuals who from time to
time on account of in discipline are
then displayed that cannot be taken as a
weakness if anything it is chlorination
and distillation of our own internal
processes you're pushing the boundaries
in this country aren't you you're
pushing the boundaries in a country that
has been essentially an authoritarian
state since independence since nineteen
eighty that is going to make a lot of
people in the administration feel very
uncomfortable and I wonder if that is
why we saw riot police turning up at
your press conference today what is your
message to those people in government
who don't like you don't like your
message don't like the fact that you've
caused you've called this election
experiment invalid in fact I I totally
appreciate that question in that it's so
pertinent in terms of how we've dealt
with our bureaucrats in government what
we seek to change I note the civil
servants who continue to be a permanent
feature of the government and they do
appreciate our message if you look at
our votes tally in a hurry we got close
to about over half a million that tells
you that it does include those who are
in government who believe in change mr.
McGregor could a few hundreds of
thousands I which tells you also that
time a lot of our people in Zimbabwe in
the cities in government to believe in
the message they are connecting with our
narrative they are connecting with our
friendly debate on how to correct the
situation remedy the mistakes of the
past and of course q are the gaps that
have characterized the governance and
the economics of our country when the
riot police turned up at the Bronte
hotel were you there
and if so what were you thinking I was
there but of course I'm used to it you
know chaos is the DNA of our colleagues
in zanu-pf
violence is their natural default
setting each time they feel that they
are threatened by an opponent they
always resort to the muscle instead of
the brain there
resort to guns and bullets instead of
respecting the power of ideas and this
is the difference but for us we are not
intimidated we sacrifice we are ready to
go to the to the logical conclusion of
our commitment to this struggle
finally what can symbol you look forward
to in the next couple of years the
economy's in a desperate State yes it's
politics are terribly divided and what
is going to happen here well we need to
heal our nation we need to unite our
country and be able to be helped again
smile again and that is only possible
with a focused leadership but more
importantly in our view we need to be
gained built bridges we need to invite
the United Kingdom the United States of
America the Western world and indeed the
entire world to be able to partner with
Zimbabwe to be able to reconstruct and
rebuild our economy but we begin also to
create solid and viable world-class
infrastructure for such a great country
we are great people allowing people with
some brilliant people from armies
engineers lawyers we need to give them a
chance an opportunity to shine and an
opportunity to be great as citizens of
the world listen to me sir thank you
very much for speaking to us on Sky News
here in central Harare on a day that mr.
Jim Issa describes as a day of mourning
the day that President man and Jaguar
was confirmed as the president of this
country with fifty point eight percent
of the vote